[Music]
on the dish this Christmas Eve morning
and the seventh night of Hanukkah Molly
yay as she says in her popular blog my
name is yay I celebrate Christmas
Hanukkah and three New Years in other
words it was the perfect time for
Michelle to make the Trek to the Upper
Midwest to see yay and her growing food
Empire on the farm
just across the North Dakota border
in East Grand Forks Minnesota
Bernie
Cafe Market and
the new hip spot on Main Street hi here
how are you doing nice to meet you it's
not a place you typically find a bona
fide celebrity foodie is it for a
Christmas present but that's where
you'll find Molly hi there greeting
customers and in the kitchen because I
think that we should Infuse it with
fresh mint leaves yeah tasting some of
her signature Confections so this is the
peppermint pastry cream and is there
vanilla in it too Bernie's is the first
brick and mortar for yay a classically
trained musician turned food blogger
turn Food Network star it's Hanukkah
it's shot right in her kitchen where she
was putting together a few of her
favorite dishes from her latest cookbook
home is where the eggs are so we've got
a little bit of everything here this is
matzabai the Jewish dish I grew up with
it my mom makes the best matzobrine this
is the second best spot surprise and
matzobrine is scrambled scrambled eggs
with more texture real excitement you
have something to chew on because you
fold broken up MATA in with the eggs and
it's cinnamon sugar with a ton of nutmeg
and it tastes like you're eating Donuts
there's a hot dish inspired by life on
the farm I don't know what a hot dish is
so a hot dish is a subset of casseroles
that has all of the food groups in it
thank you I love the spoon don't judge
you've got to have a big spoon to get
all of the layers hand pulled noodles
with pot sticker filling sauce a nod to
her Chinese Heritage really thick chewy
noodles so you're not walking away from
your table hungry no I mean that is my
biggest fear as a Jewish mother is that
anybody is walking away hungry yay's
food is a reflection of herself she was
raised in Chicago the daughter of a
Jewish mom and Chinese dad a clarinetist
in the Chicago Symphony
yay was on track to follow in his
footsteps studying percussion at
Juilliard in New York how did you
transition to cooking I mean so you're
not
formally trained as a no you know I've
worked in kitchens and I grew up in a
very musical household that also had a
lot of good food because my mom was
always cooking really good food but when
you play percussion and when you're in
an orchestra there's a lot of waiting
around for your one triangle note
for your one simple crash and it was in
those moments of rest where I started
thinking more about food and that's
where I started the blog it was around
this time she fell in love with a
trombonista jewel yard by the name of
Nick Hagan
but it turns out music wasn't in the
plans for either of them so Nick told me
he said well we have this Farm
you're like do I want to be a farmer's
wife I was like yes oh really that's
where I want to be you're digging it yes
when we moved here he went off to
harvest and he was like see ya
and I didn't see him for a good few
weeks and so I just blogged with her
bright smile and colorful food pics
yay's blog took off you had an instant
audience why do you think you connected
with so many people I don't know I
wanted to be friends with everyone and
and moving here as much as I love it I
also have no idea what it would have
been like if I had moved here without
the internet if I had moved here even 10
15 years earlier even a year earlier
because when we moved out here as we
were driving out here they were laying
the cable for high-speed internet out to
the farm wow and so on one hand it was
yes it was my job and and yes it was a
an amazing creative Outlet on the other
hand that was my social connection the
blog led to a cookbook Molly on the
Range then to a call from the Food
Network they're so fluffy which launched
girl meets Farm in 2018.
Kitty that's only
hey Ollie yay took me out on the
snow-covered range this is our field
we're in warmer months Nick grows grain
soybeans and sugar beets
we're going to the party so this is
where Nick works on all of the machinery
and that must be Nick there he is hello
in the off season he maintains the heavy
machinery needed for modern farming with
help from his dad who's passing on his
family's Farm to the fifth generation
there's just some things that are almost
bigger than yourself and I feel like
that's what this Farm is theirs is a
very modern fairy tale so agriculture it
was sort of probably the first industry
Molly's business it's so new you know if
you think about the social media aspect
of it or being in television you just
never would take that for granted right
so so 146 year old Farm meets
six-year-old blog you know
um
excuse me yay admits that she felt a bit
like a fish out of water here at first
do you miss the big cities Chicago New
York
I miss deep dish pizza
and New York slices but for a day-to-day
waking up and seeing this this is
energizing for me this is where I like
to come home to
it's where she'll be celebrating the
holidays both Hanukkah and Christmas
with her family and of course her
viewers Merry Christmas to us and ours
am I doing good perfect yes for the dish
Molly whipped up her version of a
holiday classic Hava Buckeyes cheers
made with one of her favorite
ingredients no less tahini and they're
just as creamy the chocolate's my jam
chocolate
I love her Molly I'm With You Christmas
in Hanukkah and our producer Greg's wife
Christine made us these Buckeyes eat
some Buckeyes eat some Buckeyes
Wolverines eat Buckeyes for breakfast
baby yeah
playoff up coming here good I know early
on oh those are good
oh crap should say a buckeye is good
because that would be bad for a
wolverine to say this is really good I
think they're good don't you wonder how
long Nick waited before saying hey by
the way I want to move to
she was all in she loved it yeah she
wanted to be the farmer big ass Ted we
love it we will be right back welcome
back we also have with us yeah we have
the eggnog with a little this little
bourbon if you wanna partake interesting
which clearly I do and Brooke does
Jeff's not
Jeff it's good for your throat a little
bourbon a little hot toddy I don't think
that's actually a little cold toddy I
mean they say that you think it is for
just a few minutes but then then it goes
south yeah is that what happens oh
that's pretty good no my throat is
better I was like yeah
I think it's just no water cheers well I
want to get under underneath the foam I
see okay are you guys Christmas shocked
by the way we were making fun earlier
saying if people are not I am yeah I
finished I think I I think I did a
decent job I hope I mean I'll find out
tomorrow you'll know yeah I grew up our
family was late for everything including
holiday shopping so I've tried to you
know respond to this are you the
opposite way in most things I am
although with holiday shopping I can be
hit or miss but yeah no I'm I'm good and
are you celebrating with family
yes in-laws coming in today nice yeah
very good we're driving up to see uh my
folks up in Rhode Island right after
this fantastic and you're hitting a
plane heading off to Boston I'll beat
the Celtics Christmas Day game we want
two wins in a row beat the boss
I always say it's a good ones for
Christmas yeah it's my first Christmas
Day game in person I've never been able
to go to anyone wow cool yeah